Collinwood there on the team together  for wiping our breath getting the work  done right yeah I remember that song was  written by the famous musician loser oh  oh yes Air Hogs hooked us up they saw  our Star Wars drone video and they  emailed us and they said hey you know  those toys that you use you guys want  more this is the enterprise Nico over  there as a looks like kylo Ren stuff  better  where did they put all the people when  they go into hyperdrive like they puts a  fan right in the center and the body's  Hollow it's really cool only thing to do  at this point is to put them together  and embrace  it weighs 1,500 pounds or something this  thing only has rear-wheel drive to get  up to the top and it just gets stuck  our it doesn't even go over the little  stuff powerful enough to get up the ramp  we only need really strong people  yeah statehood side slightly to their  and  Hey  start